i apologize in advance i'm with
comicbook.com i do have to ask some
nerdy questions um i i know you can't
confirm or deny always qui-gon jin is
making an appearance in obi-wan so i'm
not even gonna ask that but would just
would you be interested in returning to
qui-gon if given the opportunity oh i
think so yeah yeah yeah i think so
um
if it was a film
uh oh yeah oh okay when it comes to tv i
must have met but no you're not excited
you know i can't believe
it's 24
years since we made uh the phantom
menace i just can't believe but their
time has gone i know
but it was a it was a traffic experience
shooting now
the big screen just project it on the
wall of your garage in your backyard
that's how we're going to watch obi-wan
episodes
well this is a very interesting quote
from leonie it's like 24 years hmm like
someone you've been in a conversation
recently about how long it's been since
you've been on screen in live action i'm
just saying like unless he's got uh
every year he has a tally mark on his
wall he's like now we're at 23 years now
we're at 24 years
so when these interviewers chris i love
this dance can't give away anything
yeah it's because it's hilarious little
sub genre of interview content right now
where these actors who are out promoting
other things get asked things about
marvel or star wars and they have to
cope with this little tap dance and
they're all good at it in interesting
ways but well it's a lot of money and a
lot of money you'll lose if you don't do
it the right if you say the wrong thing
yeah we want to thank comicbook.com and
chris killian for the great interview
moment with liam neeson thank you for
always asking such great questions and
let's get into this welcome back to new
rock stars liam neeson finally breaks
the silence and returning as qui-gon
jinn and it turns out his particular set
of skills are only for cinema
none of this buffering [ __ ] you
stream on your cracked 24-inch vizio
that folds back into the wall michael
scott style nope no only amc imax where
if it's here it's real if nicole kidman
doesn't greet or doesn't greet you
before the film standing sitting eating
popcorn drinking a sprite then i don't
want to be in it yeah no qui-gon
qui-gon's not there for the small screen
baby he's not there for your phone
unless they're tablets for moses but the
reason we laugh about this is you know
liam neeson has lent his iconic voice to
many tv series and streaming titles over
the years including voicing qui-gon jinn
in the clone wars so is this only in a
film quote actually a
a bit of a tap dance a cover story for
what will actually be a real cameo in
general
[Laughter]
i just scared a cat i think every
morning they're just cats that just howl
when we start this show just like not
today please not today not again not
again oh
well ever was there ever a show so
clever as eric and tommy talk in star
wars
the musical theater people are gonna be
back on board with you eric you've got a
lot of they're like oh our kitty ears
are burning and they all do their creepy
little march where they zip their
fursuits off and there's more fur
underneath well you're my jellicle
choice always eric you're always my
jellicle choice the amount of weeks i've
tried to force um
gus the theater cat into talking about
gus the goldfish on moon night and just
haven't had a good window for it yet
because you know mt would shut that [ __ ]
down enough
not interesting he will not suffer that
uh well this week on wikileaks we're
gonna break down the likelihood of
qui-gon jinn making an appearance in the
obi-wan kobe series and if that happens
what fascinating conversation will they
have because they got a lot to talk
about a little later this episode we're
gonna discuss which star wars music has
had the biggest impact
uh because star wars is music and john
williams has been an equal partner in
the success of this franchise it's not
absolutely the leading reason it's been
successful depending on who you talk to
time is running now to grab yourself the
limited edition moon night latest
obsession shirt over at new
rockstarsmerch.com those bad boys are
gonna get banished back into ushapti
form very quickly uh to make room for
the multiverse of madness latest
obsession shirt that's gonna be great so
they're running out i don't know how
many we have left i don't think it's
much so grab one of those and all kinds
of cool merch that helps support the
channel at newrockstarsmerch.com and oh
another pretty big announcement from new
rockstars the channel is going to be
launching a daily live stream show
starting a week from today monday may
2nd uh tommy is going to be part of it
other folks behind the scenes a new
rockstar some familiar faces are going
to be on it this is going to be a live
in-person shoot that gives you a
behind-the-scenes uh uh kind of chit
chat that happens every day yes at the
new rockstars burbank office just a
little heads up i am not at that burbank
office i'm here in uh san francisco the
blue dungeons everywhere but
usually it's it's in uh san francisco
yes uh so i'm not going to be joining
that conversation every week but it's
going to show you the amazing
conversation that happens behind the
scenes it's going to be super funny i've
seen some early test screenings you may
have seen one on the channel on thursday
uh so you'll be able to like get a peek
into the the fun amazing mind of tommy
bechtold and friends
terrified from the terrifying visionary
mind of tommy bechtel no we're and uh
we're very excited and unfortunately
we cannot summon eric by saying his name
three times uh like beetlejuice although
we wish we could but hopefully when you
do that i get transported to some weird
dimension that it's neither here nor
there yes it's just not fair to you
because we never know where you're going
to end up so yeah so we we hope eric
will join us at some point down in the
mothership but until then we will we'll
march along and uh we're gonna have a
lot of fun on that show but we're gonna
have a lot of fun on this show now eric
yeah we are this this ain't going
anywhere guess what the break room that
starts may 2nd last time i checked it's
april something
25th and and when that launch yeah it's
a week from now but
like this isn't going to be replacing
any of the content you see on the
channel we're still going to be we're
going to be doing even more blue screen
uh solos videos more breakdowns of shows
more after shows the reasons that you
already subscribed to new rockstars
those aren't going anywhere we're going
to be doubling down on those in addition
to launching this yeah it's a crazy time
of expansion at this channel you're just
all so hungry for content we gotta feed
you
feed me we're talking yeah um but
we're doing it let's see how many
musicals we can fit in today we'll work
it all in
when this launch is next monday you'll
be able to actually start watching every
weekday afternoon monday through friday
starting next week on the new rockstars
youtube channel so keep an eye out for
that it's gonna be real fun um all right
so talking star wars and liam neeson
this week tommy what's up what's our big
question for star wars well as we saw in
that interview we're all wondering will
liam neeson cameo is qui-gon jinn or not
yeah liam neeson seemed to deny
appearing in the obi-wan kenobi series
saying at first that he'd be interested
but then suddenly catching himself and
saying oh but film yeah suggesting that
he's a snob and would only want to be on
the big screen as qui-gon jin i think
that's such a tell the fact that he
insulted himself and called himself a
snob like that's such a yeah that's such
a tell that he knew he was getting in
troubled waters he's like i'm just gonna
charm my way out of this yeah and i
thought it was a pretty good answer it's
just one that like we we know like
because it's a very artificial excuse
because nissan has never held himself
that to that before sure he's known as
more of a film actor but he's totally
appeared in a number of tv roles in
streaming series uh you mentioned family
guy he was in
netflix's the ballot buster scruggs
which people streamed on their home tvs
just actors these days know as well as
anyone that content right now just being
streamed on home devices uh and it's not
like liam neeson has been a stranger to
lucasfilm in recent years because he
voiced qui-gon's ghostly presence in
three episodes of the clone wars season
three episode 15 overlords when
qui-gon's force ghost tells obi-wan
about mortis and then followed by the
amazing episode 17 when qui-gon's ghost
meets obi-wan in mortis to tell about
those three force deities the father the
son and the daughter and they're
interested in anakin folks this is a
hugely important arc for the star wars
lore in mythology everything we know
about ahsoka why she has the the bird
her connections her deeper mystical
connections to uh anakin skywalker in
fact like there was a believed earlier
draft of the rise of skywalker that
might have addressed the dagger of
mortis and that's why this random dagger
was in the movies that this is gonna be
the dagger of mortis and then they
backed away from that and then ended up
making it into a goonies clue but
this insanely important storyline from
the clone wars
liam neeson was there for it he is what
lent it so much authority was just his
voice bringing us into that mystery um
now liam neeson did come back in season
six episode 11 of clone wars you know
one of these uh we aren't sure where the
series is going at this point star wars
uh
episodes of this final season of clone
wars right before they canceled it but
it's still an awesome episode to check
out um qui-gon appears to yoda in this
episode um but then of course nisa comes
back in the rise of skywalker in 2019 he
was one of the many jedi voices who
returned so the guy has had no problem
uh checking in with dave filoni in an
adr booth
multiple times in recent years yes
so uh yeah when we watch this interview
now it just looks like the kind of
denial game we've seen before where
these poor guys gotta sit through junket
after junket promoting other movies that
they're more passionate about in this
moment and then they have to have some
kind of like
answer for when the marvel or the star
wars question inevitably comes up so i i
completely i empathize uh i guess i
can't really empathize i sympathize what
neeson's going through in this moment
and and i love the guy um but if
lucasfilm could get ewan mcgregor and
hayden christensen to return and to be
the stars of the show just a vocal cameo
by liam neeson the very least after he's
done this multiple times a day polonius
just it feels very likely and i think
set photos from entertainment weekly
even show us the moment obi-wan reunites
with qui-gon's force ghost or some force
ghost like we take a look at this photo
it shows obi-wan alone in his cave
dwelling but this weird blue light that
lights up the room just in this dim way
and it looks like the source of the
light at least in the foreground is
coming from from the foreground because
it's on our side of this uh cave archway
and it's reflecting back at us so it's
like he woke up in the middle of the
night and then looks out in the darkness
of the cave in astonishment as of seeing
a familiar face
because otherwise no one knows where he
lives he's a hermit who else would be in
this room who else would he be looking
at or greeting in this moment if not a
force ghost of qui-gon jen or
a dream of uh of
uh hayden christensen uh
anakin skywalker or yoda or you know who
knows jar jar
um but i think what's interesting about
re-watching those ghosts of mortal
scenes with qui-gon is how resolute the
character still is even in death that
anakin skywalker
in his mind was the chosen one
so if obi-wan and qui-gon reunite in the
series this will be the first time
qui-gon is really challenged with the
inevitable truth that his recruitment of
anakin
doomed all of them uh and at least at
this point in history feels like a huge
mistake uh and it feels like we're gonna
get a parallel actually to luke's chat
with obi-wan's force ghost on dagobah
and return the jedi where obi-wan
famously told him well which i told you
what's true from a certain point of view
yeah what does that mean you're
gaslighting me and tommy how amazing is
it going to be if obi-wan got that
[ __ ] line from his former mask of
qui-gon like quang could say well
skywalker was the chosen one from a
certain point of view and then obviously
that and use that
hope he wants just writing it down in a
joke journal he's like hang on a second
i i always keep one of these with me
just in case uh when they're in their
netherworlds of the force appearing in
his sports coast it's just like written
on the back of the guitar there and
they're like
tommy i want to ask you how do you think
qui-gon will react and respond when
obi-wan calls him out for bringing
anakin into their lives is he going to
apologize or is he going to be like just
wait just wait bringing in the
skywalkers into this is actually
in the big frame big frame of reference
actually going to be more important than
you think just historically force ghosts
on in the movies anyway from what i can
say are pretty stoic right like they're
pretty
they're pretty like level-headed and
even keeled and they don't necessarily
show a ton of like emotion or like i
can't see him getting like angry
although it would be amazing if like we
know liam neeson as qui-gon like
just getting annoyed with obi-wan but i
think more than likely what you said the
the first thing you said where he'll be
like
maybe it didn't end up the way i thought
it would but it's going to
reach uh the conclusion we want just
with a different skywalker
maybe he'll say there is another maybe
he'll say
there is another
huh and obi-wan's just
yo everyone's just plagiarizing qui-gon
yoda's plagiarizing well my i think it'd
be fun if like i like it when force i
like the way ghosts in all fiction are
kind of sassy yeah
yeah they they've like learned nothing
from being in this realm they've just
become more petty
shitty versions of themselves yeah um
because i think that's what ghosts
become i don't think they become like
spiritual or zen in any way i think
they're just like they're little
stinkers you know so they're like
beetlejuice so i
i'm a think stinker ghost i'm a little
stinker
stinker was deleted from ghostbusters
afterlife because he tested so poorly
with audiences
and then they got moved to ghostbusters
yeah but i think uh i think why god's
gonna be a a jackass and he's gonna be
really mean uh and say no don't tell me
that i'm wrong i did the right thing uh
eventually corruption was going to
collapse the senate but i gave us a new
hope in the form of his offspring uh and
that's why it's so important to continue
this mission because while anakin wasn't
the chosen one the chosen one was
swimming around in one of his nutsacks
it's too early for that everyone's like
oh stinker
it's too early i would just woke up in
this cave let me go back to bed leave
here alone and watch that has not sucked
so
i just think this is a great place to
have this argument about like
you know uh the balance to the force did
happen because the jedi needed to be
called out on their [ __ ] now yes i
sounds like i'm creating a
justification for genocide and slaughter
of children of jedi of jedi order no not
at all but i think uh i think this story
the story needed to happen because we
needed our mythology stories to make our
videos about yeah
um they did it for us
i think there's a great meta textual
conversation that can happen between
these two characters it needs to happen
between these two characters and i want
to see in the form of a crass angry
ghost
i'm 100 on board with you here i have no
pushback on that that is how i want it
to happen too neeson can do it yes
nissan is a great actor get liam get
this man a script i assume they already
have whatever if he's not in the show
i'm not gonna be mad just uh show us the
qui-gon cut i'm gonna demand us to see
the question give us the quiet gone cut
i want to talk star wars music with
tommy but first let's people to thank
for helping us make this episode
starting with master class thank you to
master class for sponsoring this episode
with masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace you can learn how to
sing for mariah carey improve your
communication skills from george
stephanopoulos or learn how to make a
pastry from the guy who invented the
cronut with over 100 classes from a
range of world-class instructors the
thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think here at new
rockstars we become very fond of giving
master classes a gift producer zack gave
a subscription to his mother-in-law and
she's been just pounding through some
classes dan brown joyce carol oates
other mother-in-law approved master
classes so one of the cool things we
have been exploring is a new audio mode
you could take a master class like you
would listen to a podcast or an
audiobook learn how to write better
fiction or be a better leader while you
drive to the pharmacy whatever you want
to do so i highly recommend you check it
out get unlimited access to every master
class and for the wookie leaks audience
you can get 15 off an annual membership
so go to masterclass.com
wookie right now that's masterclass.com
wookie with two e's for 15 off master
class and we want to thank mint mobile
for sponsoring this episode after years
of fine print contracts and getting
ripped off by big wireless providers we
are jazzed about mint mobile and their
premium wireless starting at just 15
bucks a month we're jazzed about all
that jazz some might say mint mobile's
secret sauce is that they're the first
company to sell wireless service online
only so they cut the cost of retail
stores and pass those sweet savings
directly to you we've got multiple folks
on staff at new rockstars who have
switched to mint mobile including editor
riley phillip they have great service
and they are laughing all the way to the
bank with those sweet sweet savings mint
mobile gives you the best rate whether
you're buying for one or buying for a
whole family and it meant families start
at two lines so all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network so use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan and keep your same
phone number along with all your
existing contacts to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plans shipped to your door
for free go to mint mobile.com wookie
with two e's that's mint mobile.com
wookie cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com
wookie all right tommy uh you and i like
talk a lot but we also like to listen a
lot to music whether it's um it's being
alive or finishing a hat or any number
of sondheim jammers uh in this case
we're talking star wars because john
williams is returning to the obi-wan
kenobi series contributing the main
theme of it however it was reported last
week that natalie holt the composer and
violinist who did the music for loki
marvel's loki on disney plus will be
doing most of the music composition for
the obi-wan kenobi series as well and
since music is so critical to star wars
i wanted to spend the second half of the
episode on our favorite music tracks
throughout the star wars history uh the
ones that carry the most narrative
weight the ones that hit us the hardest
emotionally the ones that might deserve
more appreciation so tommy let's start
with
of all the different star wars tracks
john williams in the original trilogy
john williams in the prequel trilogy uh
michael giaccino's work for uh for rogue
one stuff from the streaming series from
clone wars or the live action streaming
series uh by ludwig jordanson uh what
star wars track do you think does the
most to carry the story narratively so
they can just use this song to just like
bridge the gap between confusing or
controversial plot points uh
you know i'm gonna say something that
might be
uh not a popular answer here but this is
something i always thought worked and i
think that's ray's theme in the force
awakens
we're immediately like just the kind of
like upbeat but like
frenetic pace of the dude
whatever and like you immediately know
like
this is a like you get her character you
get like she's restless she doesn't want
to be there we don't even know her yet
but she's got a lot to do even though
she doesn't want to do it but she needs
to get those credits so she can get her
weird bread that's dehydrated yeah um i
mean it probably tastes like a sponge
but damn it looks yummy um i agree with
you tommy i think uh i think the ray
theme from the force awakens and the way
it's used throughout the sequel trilogy
is a beautiful piece of music and i love
it i love hearing it i i think it has
such an interesting different texture it
gives you it does the most character
development i think of
of most of the star wars things most of
the star wars tracks have this epic uh
cosmic implications feel to them or this
adventure spirit or a sense of doom this
just
feels very intimate uh and just it feels
like you're spending a quiet private
moment with a character which uh is one
of the reasons why those opening beats
of force awakens are so great um
for me i think and this is gonna sound
like i'm saying it's the most overused
but i'm not i just think it it's such a
good track that it just you hear it
almost every episode of all the animated
series it's just the force theme binary
sunset
[Music]
i just think it is used so often just to
imbue meaning into a moment and it works
it works on me every time i will never
complain when you hear a force-themed
light motif uh brought in to bridge the
gap between two characters just whenever
a lightsaber appears on screen uh it's
like you hear the force theme come back
and it works it it always works uh it it
draws you back into that arthurian
legend that uh that george lucas started
the series as and i think it
it it's uh it has carried all star wars
titles more than i think any other
musical uh sting has
no absolutely yeah
um all right let's move on to the next
question what do you think the most
underappreciated star wars music is
i think the most disrespected uh star
wars music because of how people feel
about
currently the maligning of these movies
is kylo ren's
uh theme that man
i'm singing it wrong but you know
whatever but uh but i think like that
initial i forget like in this i have the
force awakening soundtrack and it's like
kylo ren the song the track is like kylo
ren attacks or something like that and
it's just the like driving like
like menacing haunting theme song
you know kylo ren's character was a
little uneven obviously in those movies
and we never i i felt
unsatisfied but i
ultimately enjoyed the character and i
think the music was wonderful for it
yeah i think um i think the music that
john williams composed
yes that's yeah that's what i was trying
to do yes it's such a chilling moment
like the hairs on the back of my neck go
up whenever i hear it i get goose bumps
and i think it's because it reminds us
of the fearsomeness that that character
almost had at the beginning of that
trilogy i think it would have been
better as a villain it's just a
completely lost i didn't need redemption
for kylo ren i think in that series no
because it was crazy that it was han
solo and leia's son
and he was awful he was a terrible
person who murdered people
indiscriminately i mean i don't know i
guess there's arguments that every
character is worthy of redemption and
that we needed to see that redemption
some of those emotional beats in the
rise of skywalker when harrison ford
came back
it worked on me the first time i saw it
so i don't i don't really know at this
moment how i feel about it but i do know
i love that music and you're right tommy
it is underappreciated it's it's it's
wonderful to me what uh the track that
doesn't get enough love because everyone
talks about duel the fates everyone
talks about the original trilogy themes
uh to me that doesn't get enough love
is the uh the across the stars the love
theme from attack of the clones
attacking the clones most people agree
is the weakest star wars installment i i
guess i don't know if everyone agrees on
that i i i love the clone wars series
that is set at the same time uh and
there's obviously a lot of parallels
there but just like the the romantic arc
between padme and anakin in that uh
movie
is something that often feels a bit hard
to connect with right but the music
works so hard to connect them and it has
this great dr shivagoin uh dr chivago
and feel this connection between them
that is just beautiful i think the the
it plays over the wedding uh the secret
wedding between them and when you just
listen to that music it just like hits
you in this like
beautiful way i think it stands up with
uh some of the other love themes that uh
that john williams has composed for this
so if you get a moment check it out i
mean a lot of the prequel tracks whether
it's uh like the battle the heroes that
we talked about in the kenobi trailer
that's really great uh john williams is
doing amazing work that is not the
famous tracks that you recognize him the
moment you hear it all the the tracks
that you hear from him have uh some
beauty and some conflict within them
that are great
all right tommy let's talk about the
best music from a star wars streaming
series so this can be from um
mandalorian bad batch or uh clone wars
or boba fett or rebels this is a
no-brainer for me i do not care how you
feel about this series i don't like that
that's not important the end credit
theme song to book above effect where
they're just saying
over and over again
all right that's that's my favorite um
yeah i love it yeah
i mean i loved it
i sat through the credits of every
single one of those it's just so rare
that you hear vocals yeah star wars
track like you hear duel of the fates
you hear the chorus there but um so they
bring in this chanting that just sounds
so cool
i love what ludwig jordanson did for um
the mandalorian i thought it was game
changing in so many ways especially the
grogu theme um
it so i i think everyone kind of agrees
that
there's some beautiful uh music that
goerson created there some instruments
we had never heard in star wars
composition before but for me i want to
give some love to kevin keiner's uh
music from the final arc of clone wars
season seven the mandalore arc uh those
final four episodes specifically just
re-watch the final episode of clone wars
season seven and the music just feels so
bleak and terrifying in a way it
reminded me of like blade runner there's
a lot of synth tones like so like the
moment when they when maul is defeated
and they're leaving
uh they're finally leaving mandalore and
they're bringing them back to coruscant
for trial uh like you know ahsoka makes
her goodbye with bo katan and like the
music has this kind of languid moody
feel to it because you know what's
coming you know execute order 66 is
coming so like it shouldn't feel like a
victory it should feel like
we're slowly marching toward the end of
our times right now and that's he
there's
not a whole lot of dialogue in that
final episode of clone wars like i think
like the final act of it maybe has one
line in it and it's like ahsoka going oh
no
and that's it the rest of it is dialogue
free it's just the music carrying it and
it's one of my favorite moments that
we've seen on star in a star wars
anything in recent years it's just so
beautiful yeah um
so i think the music's a huge part of
that the uh all right tommy yes what
star wars music brings you to tears the
quickest oh why any song by max revo uh
no uh
i think um
this is so cheesy
the han and leia theme always makes me a
little bit misty when they did it when
they brought it back for force awakens i
got more than a little misty
uh
i just love that sauna yeah it's such a
great theme it's beautiful for me yeah
uh for a while it was uh leia's theme
for me but i think
it only became leah's theme when carrie
fisher died uh i i've always loved
leia's theme
what is it
[Music]
wow we really are musical today oklahoma
i think really the one that has gotten
me lately is yoda's theme
[Music]
oh yes yes
yeah
yeah and maybe it's just the way that
it's uh come back in the mandalorian and
in boba fett but yoda's theme
and uh so in los angeles and tommy i i
don't know if you've ever been to this
but like every labor day week and john
williams will do a concert at the
hollywood bowl yeah um and all the star
wars nerds come out they bring their
lightsabers and they'll play a selection
of a bunch of different scores he'll
drop a little harry potter on you he'll
do some indiana jones but then he gets
to what you really want
and uh now he just does the second act i
believe the first act is done by the uh
another great composer david newman who
is uh i think he's the conductor of the
la philharmonic but he's composed uh he
comes from a long family of composers
starting with alfred oh yes because he
knew him he knew john williams when he
was like a little boy right there yeah
he grew up like you met him when he was
six
he's an old family friend and that guy
was like in a way a mentor to john
williams and i believe
alfred did that
[Music]
the fox 20th century theme but it's an
amazing thing to watch if you're ever in
los angeles labor day weekend absolutely
get a ticket they're not too expensive
and there's no bad seat in the house at
the hollywood bowl it's just a nice
night a nice warm night thing to do the
picnic yeah if you live in l.a it's a
it's a must do and if you can't do that
they also usually once a year we'll do
live um to screen
uh orchestra matching for the movies so
you can see like return of the jedi with
with the la philharmonic and that's
really that's really cool as well those
are really fun to do too yeah um but i
think the last one i was able to see uh
would have been
i guess last year i i think we went
august 2021 but um they did he played
yoda's theme and then they glow the
whole bowl green uh and it there's just
something about the music that like
uh can connect with you
on a personal level it's not about your
connection with someone else necessarily
which is a lot of the other star wars
songs have like an inherent relationship
to them it's about um your ability to
overcome an obstacle and to realize what
you thought was just impossible is
possible there's so much hope in the
song and i think it's beautiful that
when you're in a dark place when you
just hear that music it fills your heart
in a way that um not every star wars
song is designed to do but this is meant
to be the light that gets you out of the
darkness uh and i think that's why like
whenever i hear it i'm like yeah yeah as
bad as things are there's hope you know
now uh last one i just want to ask best
needle drop
like any time this is dropped
it gets your blood i'm gonna be
a real basic
basic boy here and i'm going to say the
imperial march of course drop the needle
[Music]
yeah and i'm like i'm raising the roof
i'm dabbing i'm dabbing for the empire
people in the other seats next to me are
begging me to stop so i'm hitting them
in the face
i love it i will always love the
imperial march and again imperial march
like the force theme is uh is getting
mileage in every star wars like you
watch rebels the amount of time the
imperial march just sneaks back in there
and rebels are like we get it we know
we know this is a bad time for everyone
i mean i say it's basic and i
acknowledge it because literally
we find out in solo a star wars movie
that the empire
has co-opted the imperial march as their
theme song in their recruitment videos
right yeah
even they and i think that's like i'll
always love it um it's just like the
amount of times the imperial march has
been like
commercialized yeah and and like used in
kfc commercials when the prequels were
coming out i was like okay come on but i
i do love it i will always like go nuts
and like i think that's that's what
he'll john williams will do a different
selection every time but i think he'll
always do the imperial march because you
can't you can't not do it it's like not
playing let it be if you're going to see
paul mccartney come on for me it's uh
the best needle drop is like this is why
i lost my mind when we saw the kenobi
trailers a duel of the fates yes
that's a great one like yes and it might
just be the generation of star wars i
grew up with i grew up with the prequels
so like that to me was the anthem of the
prequel no you're so you're right that's
a better one just because no i don't i
think for most people imperial marches
probably but
we're we both kind of those those
prequels were our first chance to really
see new star wars and theaters for you
and i
and uh i mean duel of fates was on trl
was on total request which is going to
date us but it was like it was a music
video that was like charting on the
music video charts like a star wars
orchestra
song was
charged like was rising up the music
video most popular charts it's crazy
when i was a kid um my older siblings
went to florida state university and we
would always go to the football games
there uh and
the marching band at florida state is
awesome they have an amazing like arts
and music department there so there was
one game where as a kid i just like i
didn't i didn't care about the game at
all i was just sitting there on the
bleachers like all right i hate being
here uh this isn't for me but then at
half time the marching band came out and
played uh duel the fates
and they had i guess they also got
the the vocals department to tell all
the marching band kids to all go
gara
and then they got into some like stunt
fighters to like reenact the fight
that's amazing
and oh i got an obi-wan and i was like
ugh
is awesome
it was like the coolest thing i've ever
seen it just felt like
duel debates was a star wars anthem that
wasn't my dad's star wars it was a star
wars song that slapped just as hard as
all those just for shots for me
just for us we want to know your
thoughts on all these questions what do
you think what star wars track deserves
more love what star wars song or
composition from the streaming series do
you think more people should listen to
or check out and which one gets those
water works flowing and who's going to
have the balls to say the kanto bright
casino lounge singers is their favorite
song who's going to have that
there's someone out there
there is someone out there who feels
that way and uh i want to hear from you
so we'll leave it there for this episode
of wikileaks don't forget to check out
our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea
boss follow tommy at tommybechdel follow
new rockstar subscribe to wikileaks
wherever you get your podcasts we thank
you so much for watching we'll see you
next week goodbye
you